so it's been a pretty crazy day so far
um just checking my emails in one second
so let me give you the recap then
garyvee up in the office - rabbit rabbit
wolf is do small notes about ownership
and leverage a period sectors that
outdoors average
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll be away
[Music]
we give you the recap big meeting
Viacom Business Insider the Tebow triple
left internal team a client I can't
mention quick little brunch couple phone
calls med panel here now at the female
quant and meeting without Jack Dorsey
CEO of Twitter and for fifteen pretty
productive day a couple other big
meetings CMO dinner tonight and then out
tomorrow morning every day I think
people are thinking about it from a
defensive standpoint and everybody's got
some version of this whether it's two
left or two right you know I think
that's so much of what's going on in the
conversation social media in our society
so I don't know if it's a blind spot or
if it's been accepted I don't know if
that everybody accepted it as well I
just think everybody defaults to defense
and they're finding which one of the
words they want to come out of their
mouth I think it's a I think it's the
baseline of how people are thinking
oh we crazy tell me you know no it's
funny you said that and you know I
haven't real I mean I've done one or two
wine videos in 60 years after doing them
every day 6000 of every day for five
years but my new infatuation with
podcasting and audio I think I'm going
to do a monthly wine podcast on my ass
on my Gary Vee audio experience where I
drink wine with some people who can
slurp and it's been really funny and
awkward but I have interesting people I
think it'd be really interesting content
and then we'll see how it feels
I may even reboot Wine Library TV with
Wine Library audio we'll see it's funny
that you asked me that today if you ask
me five months ago
I would entertain oh man I did it it was
a nice part of my life I like enjoying
life but now I think I see a light to a
comeback my French entrepreneurs I love
you keep hustling just remember like
nope no government no no company stops
you do your thang great sometimes thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks vortex 2018 is going to be the
best conference ever
you're just going to enter you just
going to enter it we're just going to
have people walk into something and
we'll be like there's nothing activated
and what the [ __ ] were like you're in
the board
[Music]